[Music]
Sierra is in Dayton Ohio hey Sierra
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
I'm so happy to finally speak with you
you too
what's up Oh Dave I'm single mom living
in public housing and I just want out of
my situation okay great
cool so what do you do for a living I'm
manager attorney for a fast food
restaurant what does that pay gross
yearly is probably just about 11,000 in
the years because I'm working part-time
how many kids you got I have four okay
well that's not going to do it
mathematically cause I know so we've got
what you've gots a career issue right
yeah I'm currently in school online
Indiana Wesleyan University ministration
administration business and business
admin okay and how much how long before
you get your degree November 20 20
[Music]
November of 2020 okay and is that a
two-year degree or a four-year I will be
my associates it'll be a two-year okay
all right all right and what do you plan
to do with that I want to go into
marketing real estate there's a few
different hats I want to take with that
I want my hand in a lot of things I also
have a excuse me a nursing facility
nursing background you do perfect
assistant background not nursing but
yeah
okay and how long did you long did you
do that since 2009 what's the most money
you've ever made in your life in one
year in one year well probably about the
same of me no I'm sorry I was double
that I was probably about 20 grand
okay all right I'll do your babies Oh
ten nine - and six months seven months
okay you got family around well my mom
passed in 2010 and my father's a truck
driver so pretty much all the time gone
but my grandfather is probably my
backbone gotcha okay all right good
well the the thing that I hear more than
anything else is is that you've got
these babies to feed and you've got to
try to find a way to create income and
what is the best thing you can do to
create income the most income the
fastest and I think you go ahead with
the fast food thing until you've got
something better but I think you start
looking today because I think you can if
you could find a full-time gig making 30
or 40 now which you probably could do
with the nursing thing and who's
watching the kids if you're doing that
but daycare yeah they're in daycare and
I do get assistance with that okay
all right if you were not in public
housing would you still get assistance
with the daycare probably but probably
not as much as yeah okay well what I
want you to use is the assistance in
wisely
meaning that you're using it as a
platform to jump from not a hole to get
stuck in yeah and so what we've got to
do is we have to find something to get
your income up long term and short term
short term is 16 jobs you know working
everything in sight doing anything
cleaning houses walking dogs babysitting
I don't care what you're doing but
you're making money doing it and and you
get you know you get your mind set move
from eleven thousand dollars a year to
eleven thousand dollars a month right we
start heading that way and it might be
some kind of a side hustle thing it's
just simple I mean a babysitting service
it could be a house cleaning service it
could be a I don't care what it is it
may have something maybe with your
nursing background that you could find a
place to you know there may be a UH an
elderly person that needs care that you
stay there and has a large home and you
stay in the basement with the kids you
know that kind of a thing that could be
your way out but but we've got to have
short-term and long-term ways to create
dollars and when you start finding those
that's going to be your possibilities
for moving out I can't give you a lot of
mathematical hope on $11,000 with four
kids okay that's not going to get you
that's not gonna be pay the rent and
food right I do have the possibility of
going so a full-time working where I'm
at now the only reason that I've been
doing part-time is because of just
trying to juggle everything with kids
and working and it just being me and
just trying to keep my stress levels out
of minimal for obvious reasons you know
I'm just trying to exist kiddo I
understand I don't blame you so I think
what you've got to do is you have to
identify which things we're going to
work on and what areas I'm going to
embrace some stress to have less stress
in another area okay an example of that
is I'm going to embrace the stress of
being in school and working all the time
so that I can get out of school make
more money so I don't have to work all
the time you know it's like I'm gonna
work I'm gonna embrace that stress right
now because it's my way out it's my skin
it's my escape mechanism and but it's
not a isn't it the problem with stress
is you can do anything
stress wise and time wise and fatigue
wise you can bust through anything if
you can see the end of it but where you
feel like you're a rat in a wheel the
stress becomes overwhelming
friend of mine refers to it as when
you're up to your neck in alligators you
can only think about alligator exactly
that's exactly right that's how it feels
and so the thing is you can deal with
alligators if you go all I got to do is
swim through swim pass three more of
them and I'm going to be over there and
and and over there is where life is
better you know and I and so just keep
scratching and clawing through so that's
why I think you've got to have a game
plan on laying out exactly where you're
going how you're going to get there and
don't be vague about it and make sure
when you're spending time that you're
making the most possible money for that
time and I'm not sure a fast-food gig is
gonna be that you might do better than
that
income per hour then just getting that
as a full-time gig I don't know maybe if
you went from part-time to full-time it
goes from 11 to 35 if it does that it's
something to look at that could be your
first step out right but you embrace
some stress now so that you don't have
to later it's just like you embrace the
stress of running two miles so you have
less weight you know it's the same thing
you we always embrace some kind of
stress with an end in mind though and
with an end in sight otherwise it's too
much and you can't bear it you call me
back cierra anytime I can help I'd be
honored to walk with you while you're
doing this